the coronavirus pandemic has revealed
europe's vulnerabilities but also our
strengths
we teamed up with scientists and acted
decisively to save lives
together we will emerge stronger
but we cannot expect the future to
become less disruptive
our societies are changing fast and new
trends
or shocks are likely to affect our lives
this is where strategic foresight comes
in to help us
understand the challenges and
opportunities that lie ahead
with strategic foresight we can identify
major trends at play explore alternative
futures
and design forward-looking policies that
make europe more resilient
this will also support our transition to
a green
digital and fair future let's look at
one of the trends to see
how foresight can help us make right
choices today
for a more resilient europe tomorrow
we have entered a green and digital age
radically changing our job market
and the way we work renewable energy
alone
is set to provide some 3 million jobs in
europe by 2050
while robotics is moving from
traditional to smart
powered by artificial intelligence
these trends can greatly improve our
lives but they also
challenge our skills set and may leave
some people behind
strategic foresight helps us to prepare
better
and sooner for such unprecedented shifts
proposing the right responses in
education
employment or social policy
[Music]
good leadership means being decisive in
uncertain times
it also means embracing that uncertainty
taking a strategic approach
to possible futures and shaping the best
way forward
we will now reach out to other
institutions member states
and key stakeholders to look beyond the
horizon
and build our common future together
[Music]